mes chers collègues
après avoir entendu un acteur majeur du
secteur aérien nous poursuivons les
travaux de notre mission d'information
sur le développement d'une filière de
biocarburant carburant synthétique
durable et hydrogène vert par une table
ronde consacrée au monde maritime alors
que s'ouvriront demain à Brest les
Journées Européennes de la mer
je salue ce soir monsieur Stéphane
raison président du directoire de aROPA
port structure qui rassemble les pores
de Paris Rouen et Le Havre
mais Monsieur Christophe Lenormand chef
de service flotte et marin de la
Direction Générale des Affaires
maritimes de la pêche et de
l'aquaculture
alors madame Caroline nemane
adjointe au sous-directeur
voilà de
alors oui mais il faut être précis je
vous en prie
voilà de sécurité la transition
écologique de la mer c'est merci
beaucoup oui
je rappelle que cette réunion est captée
et diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat sur lequel elle pourra
ensuite être consultée en vidéo à la
demande
mesdames alors madame et Messieurs notre
mission d'information comprend des
mondes
issus des différentes commissions du
Sénat et qui représente en même temps
l'ensemble des groupes politiques de
notre assemblée le développement des
filières de biocarburant carburant
synthétique durable et hydrogène vert
sera l'un des éléments importants de la
décarbonation des transports ce sera
donc l'une des voies pour atteindre les
objectifs ambitieux que cet assigné
l'Union européenne
et notre pays au travers
du pacte vert du et du pacte ajustement
à l'objectif 55 qui comprend un volet
maritime notre mission d'information
passe en revue les enjeux des différents
modes de transport et a déjà eu
l'occasion d'aborder le secteur maritime
non pas en audition du Sénat mais sur le
terrain à Marseille et c'était de mon
point de vue très éclairant nous avons
ainsi changé avec le président du
directoire et le secrétaire général du
Grand port maritime de Marseille ainsi
qu'avec la vice-présidente du groupe CMA
CGM ce qui nous a permis d'identifier un
certain nombre d'enjeux nous avons nous
avions également auparavant eu des
échanges avec le secteur fluvial qui
constitue un maillon de la chaîne des
transports qui pourraient être
développés
nous aurons des échanges complémentaires
avec le cluster maritime français et
amateur amateur de France qui ne pouvait
pas être présent ce soir à cette table
ronde le 4 avril dernier
a été dévoilé une feuille de route de
décarbonation du secteur maritime sa
préparation avait été pilotée par le
secteur de la
dgampa et le cluster maritime français
il sera utile que vous nous la
présentiez en précisant les enjeux et
les solutions envisageables qui
paraissent assez diversifié à ce stade
nous avons également mesuré lors de
notre déplacement à Marseille ce qui
implique ce qu'implique cette
décarbonation pour les plateformes
portuaires notamment en termes
d'infrastructures
les grands ports sont aussi appelés à
devenir demain des lieux stratégiques
pour la production ou pour la transition
le transit d'hydrogène vert ou le
carburant de nouvelles générations en
cœur faut-il avoir le foncier disponible
pour développer des projets industriels
de nouvelles de nouvelles générations
mais aussi l'approvisionnement
électrique nécessaire
il nous importe donc d'avoir votre
vision sur ce dossier notre rapporteur
monsieur capot
canelas Vincent qui est à l'origine de
notre mission vous adressé un
questionnaire qui peut vous servir de
guide mais
vous développez votre introduction et
votre propos comme vous l'entendez je
passerai ensuite la parole à notre
rapporteur puis à l'ensemble de mes
collègues afin qu'ils puissent vous
relancer et vous poser un certain nombre
de questions vous pourrez nous
transmettre ultérieurement les par écrit
les réponses aux questions qui vous ont
été adressées je propose de céder en
premier lieu la parole à Monsieur
Christophe Lenorman chef de service
flotte et marin de la Direction Générale
des Affaires maritimes de la pêche et de
l'aquaculture monsieur Lenormand
quinzaine de minutes si vous dépassez on
vous en voudra pas
merci monsieur le Président je vous
propose si vous en êtes d'accord que
l'on fasse cette exposé l'iminaire à
deux voies donc avec Caroline deman et
puis bien sûr je pense comme vous voulez
prendre ensuite le la parole sur le
volet portuaire du sujet parce que
celui-ci t'as évidemment
essentiel merci en tout cas pour votre
invitation et pour essayer en tout cas
de vous apporter un éclairage des
éclairages sur ce sujet effectivement
très très central dans la stratégie de
décarbonation de la de la flotte
maritime des flottes maritimes je
voudrais dire puisque on raisonne au
pluriel et notre approche et
volontairement
globale et elle adresse évidemment le
sujet de la du transport maritime mais
on a aussi
à coeur de de traiter la question de la
détermination de la flotte de pêche la
flotte de plaisance et donc c'est pour
ça qu'on parle de notre approche
des flottes au pluriel vous l'avez
rappelé dans votre propos on s'asserre
en fait dans un contexte international
et européen sur ce sujet qui a qui a
beaucoup bougé qui est en fait le fruit
des et la transcription des de l'accord
de Paris donc
celui-ci a été mise en musique je dirais
avec le par le canal de l'Organisation
maritime internationale donc qui est
l'organisation internationale dépendant
enfin un instrument de l'ONU et qui qui
définit je dirais les normes au niveau
international pour le transport maritime
et qui logiquement s'est emparé de ce
sujet là et à défini et donc à la fois
une stratégie des objectifs pour le
transport maritime à horizon 2050 et en
rétroplanning des objectifs
intermédiaires à horizon 2040-2030
donc une stratégie globale qui a été
une première fois et qui est en cours de
révision avec une négociation en tout
cas une finalisation de de révision qui
est attendue au prochain Comité
Environnement de l'ONU qui se tiendra
début juillet à Londres et sur laquelle
sujet sur lequel la France est
extrêmement active donc une stratégie
globale de je dirais de transcription de
l'accord de Paris au niveau de l'ONU et
des premières dispositions concrètes de
mise en oeuvre
avec la définition de ce qu'on appelle
des mesures de court terme je pourrais y
revenir qui sont d'ores et les gens en
place avec des des index carbone qui ont
été définies par type de flotte et
derrière une réflexion qui est lancée en
tout cas qui est en cours de maturation
sur des mesures dites de moyen terme une
mesure de moyen terme qui sont à la fois
des mesures dites de marché et des
mesures techniques mais je pourrais
revenir un peu plus en détail donc ça je
dirais que c'est le le cadre
international dans lequel on s'inscrit
par rapport à ça il y a aussi évidemment
toute une discussion des négociations
européennes vous l'avez rappelé dans
votre propos autour de ce qu'on appelle
le paquet fit for fifty-five vous l'avez
rappelé en bon français donc prêt pour 5
voilà le les échéances qui qui sont qui
sont les nôtres avec dedans trois
instruments qui ont fait l'objet de
d'un accord il y a peu et qui ont été
beaucoup travaillés là encore sous
résidence française de l'Union
européenne l'année dernière donc le ce
qu'on appelle le marché carbone donc on
appelle le TS donc il y a un volet
maritime
la partie carburant donc avec ce qu'on
appelle le fioul you maritime donc qui
est en fait l'instrument visant à à
décarboner progressivement les les
carburants utilisés dans le dans le
secteur maritime et puis toute la partie
infrastructure donc avec ce qu'on
appelle le
l'instrument à fir et sur lequel
Stéphane raison reviendra sur plus en
détail donc ça c'est je dirais c'est le
paquet feat for fifty-five qui est
encore une fois a été a été validé
finalisé au niveau politique il y a pas
il y a pas si longtemps que ça donc on
est maintenant on va démarrer je dirais
la mise en œuvre de ces dispositions
leur transcription dans le droit
français vous aurez sans doute
l'occasion de voir passer des textes
assez titres là au niveau législatif
et donc on s'asserre dans ce cadre là et
on a été au niveau français extrêmement
actif dans la dans la négociation tant
au niveau au niveau international au mic
au niveau européen et donc dans ce
contexte là a été défini dans le cadre
de la loi climat et résilience une
feuille de route qui quelque part est
notre maintenant notre ligne de conduite
sur sur notre trajectoire en termes de
décarbonation
des flottes et en premier chef donc de
la flotte transport maritime qui
s'attache en fait à définir des
objectifs et à
identifier des leviers pour pour
parvenir ces objectifs c'est ce cette
feuille de route c'est le résultat je
dirais d'un travail qui celui de
l'ensemble de la filière
enfin des filières concernées sur toute
la chaîne de valeur donc de la
construction jusqu'à la déconstruction
donc c'est une perspective
volontairement très large et qui a
été construit je dirais à l'image de ce
qui s'est de ce qui s'est fait aussi en
parallèle pour d'autres grandes filières
qui qui sont fortement émitrices je
dirais en termes de en termes de CO2
que sont l'aérien l'automobile voilà
donc en fait on a on a inscrit notre
démarche dans cette dans ce cadre
général qui est celui de la loi climat
résilience et je propose peut-être qu'on
vous dise quelques mots sur cette
feuille de route parce que quelque part
c'est c'est un peu notre notre ligne de
conduite notre et maintenant qu'elle a
été validée et je dirais reçu par les
deux ministres à la fois le secrétaire
d'État en charge de la mer et le
ministre en charge des transports c'est
sur cette base là je dirais que son
conduit les travaux actuellement et avec
l'idée encore une fois d'avoir quelque
chose d'ambitieux mais aussi de de
réaliste et avec un certain nombre
d'instruments très concret que l'on
souhaite mettre en oeuvre au travers de
cette feuille de route donc je vous
propose si vous êtes d'accord qu'on vous
qu'on vous dise quelques mots enfin que
Caroline vous dise quelques mots sur ce
cette feuille de route
parce que je pense que c'est au cœur de
notre sujet notre sujet du jour et
évidemment vous l'avez rappelé dans
votre propos on a bien reçu le
questionnaire donc on va s'attacher à
répondre de manière détaillée aux
questions qui nous ont été adressées on
vous on vous passera ces éléments assez
rapidement et qui vous permettront
d'avoir plus de détails peut-être sur un
certain nombre de questions qui qui
était qui était remontée
et qui sont toutes effectivement autour
de ce sujet que j'évoque là de manière
générale mais on a des réponses un peu
plus précises je dirais dans le
questionnaire lui-même
Caroline je vous remercie monsieur le
Président oui quelques propos
complémentaires ceux évoqués par
Monsieur Christophe Lenormand donc c'est
cette feuille de route donc a été remise
effectivement à nos deux ministres très
récemment mais il s'agit d'une feuille
de route élaborée par la filière donc le
principe de l'article 3001 de cette loi
climat et résilience
était que ce soit la société civile qui
s'implique dans la planification
écologique et qui propose une feuille de
route donc nous sommes à ce stade donc
la DGA a piloté cette feuille de route
pour que ça ne devienne pas une une
lettre au Père Noël et aussi pour
structurer un petit peu voilà les
résultats et le la finalité de cette
feuille de route donc dans le cadre des
de la réalisation de cette feuille de
route l'intégralité effectivement des
filières ont été
ont été embarqués et nous avons
identifié un certain nombre de leviers
techniques de leviers de sobriété de
levier énergétique pour les navires
la problématique donc du transport
maritime est une que c'est navires les
navires ne sont pas construits en série
donc ce sont quasiment tous des
prototypes donc trouver les solutions de
décarbonation et l'énergie adaptée à
chaque navire et très difficile donc il
n'y a pas une solution pour tous les
navires INSA une solution pour un
certain nombre de navires en fonction de
leur type d'exploitation de leurs zones
d'exploitation dans le sur les océans de
leur type de transport passagers
cargaison en fonction aussi de leur
autonomie donc voilà donc l'exercice
n'est pas aussi simple que pourrait
l'être pour d'autres modes de transport
ou voilà les les véhicules sont
construits en série avec deux
constructeurs voilà c'est donc
l'exercice a été beaucoup plus difficile
donc nous nous sommes attelés à
identifier grâce au travail de la
filière des leviers techniques puisque
l'un des premiers sujets et de
d'améliorer l'efficacité énergétique des
navires puisque nous savons tous que il
n'y aura pas probablement et
suffisamment d'énergie
remplaçant le fossile pour alimenter
tous les navires donc il s'agit déjà de
faire un gros travail de d'amélioration
de l'efficacité énergétique des navires
donc par le biais de modifications
de nouvelles technologies embarquées de
modifications de carême d'optimisation
de l'exploitation d'information à
l'écoconduite des marins donc voilà il y
a un gros travail de sur l'efficacité
énergétique des navires il y a aussi un
travail sur la sobriété
notamment au niveau de la réduction des
vitesses voilà donc ça c'est un sujet
qui a été évoqué aussi par la des
filières et l'administration et donc il
est question également
d'envisager des réductions de vitesse
pour certaines lignes pour éviter une
surconsommation inappropriée des navires
et ensuite il y a le volet énergétique
et là nous avons
identifié plusieurs plusieurs énergies
possibles
la première que je cite puisqu'elle est
gratuite c'est le vent donc il y a un
levier énergie éolienne au travers de de
la mise à bord de voile ou de
technologie équivalente sur les navires
donc ça commence à être émergent ça nous
permettra pour un certain nombre de
Navis des gains potentiels en
comment dire en consommation de 10%.
donc voilà moi je préfère dire 10% les
on évoque 20% donc on a tendance d'avoir
une une objectivation des des gains
potentiels des performances des
nouvelles technologies donc voilà il y
aura des gains en consommation des
navires mais on attend encore d'avoir
les premiers démonstrateurs pour
vraiment arriver à objectiver ses
performances les autres énergies
possibles sur les navires donc forcément
ce sont les biophoules les biofioul
issus de la biomasse et nous avons
différencié en fait les biofuels et les
fuel donc les les carburants issus de la
biomasse et les carburants de synthèse
et parmi ces carburants donc figurent
des sous-carburants qui sont
pour la biomasse des du biogazole du bio
diesel du bio voilà tout ce que tous les
comment dire c'est un mixte de carburant
fossiles dans lequel nous allons ajouter
progressivement des carburants issus de
la biomasse voilà
l'autre type de carburant donc c'est les
carburants de synthèse donc qui se sont
produits à partir d'électricité de CO2
et de molécules d'hydrogène et d'une
autre molécule pour créer soit de
l'ammoniac soit du iméthanol soit du
diesel soit du
ifioul donc là encore nous avons pas à
ce stade
identifié de carburant qui
sortirait un petit peu plus que les
autres même si effectivement dans la
presse et au travers de vos auditions
peut-être avec des grands armateurs
français le méthanol et le iméthanol
semble voilà ce profiler
nous avons parlé aussi des des
carburants gazeux donc actuellement
effectivement un certain nombre de
navires passaux GNL donc gaz naturel
liquéfié pour l'instant c'est de
l'énergie fossile donc il est question
d'avoir une filière de biognelle ou une
filière de
ignnl donc là aussi tout ça c'est en
discussion
donc voilà il y a aussi l'énergie
électrique directe pour propulser les
navires donc là ça se discute pour des
navires à faible autonomie voilà équipé
de de batterie de batterie rechargeable
à quai il y a aussi la question de
l'hydrogène utilisée directement dans
les navires donc soit de l'hydrogène
inséré dans des piles à combustibles
soit de l'hydrogène liquide là aussi ça
concerne plutôt des des navires à faible
autonomie donc voilà tout tout ce panel
d'énergie
identifié pour
pour pour être des énergies qui
remplacent les énergies fossiles donc
actuellement nous sommes à ce stade des
discussions et nous devons
continuer ce travail de la feuille de
route en segmentant
les navires donc les flottes puisque les
solutions énergétiques des navires de
pêche ne seront pas forcément les mêmes
que les solutions énergétiques des gros
porte-conteneurs ou que des ferry à
passagers à navigation nationale ou à
navigation nationale voilà donc les
solutions énergétiques les plus
appropriées doivent être identifiés pour
chaque segment de flotte
que dire actuellement donc cette feuille
de route qui a été remise au ministre à
identifier
tout un plan d'action qu'il est
nécessaire d'étudier au sein des
différentes administrations donc nous
sommes actuellement en période
d'arbitrage pour valider cette feuille
de route donc c'est ça arbitrage se font
à deux niveaux au niveau du secrétariat
général de la planification écologique
avec lequel nous sommes en discussion
régulière pour les sujets justement de
ces
biocarburants et e-carburants et nous
nous sommes aussi en discussion avec les
autres administrations dans le cadre du
cimaire donc du comité interministériel
de la mer pour réussir à obtenir des
arbitrages notamment pour les questions
de financement
des navires en vue voilà de les
décarboner
dans cette feuille de route
que nous pouvons vous remettre à nous
avons un format un petit peu plus
sympathique que le format dématérialisé
nous nous sommes basés sur un une
trajectoire de décarbonation réalisée à
partir d'un outil de modélisation qui
applique au navire une combinaison de
leviers donc levier technologique
d'efficacité énergétique levier de
sobriété réduction de vitesse et levier
énergétique d'utilisation des
biocarburants des e-carburants et du
vent
ce scénario est actuellement en cours de
rediscution puisque dans cette feuille
de route ont été prises des options qui
ne seront peut-être pas les options
acceptées par exemple dans ce scénario
il a été pris en compte une croissance
de la flotte de 1,5% par an jusqu'en
2030 associés un rapatriant rapatriement
du soutage en France de par an pourquoi
puisque
la transition
énergétique des navires et le changement
d'énergie peut nous permettre
[Musique]
nécessite d'avoir accès à des nouveaux
carburants et si en France nous ne
créons pas des filières de nouveaux
carburants nous risquons d'avoir un
problème de souveraineté ou moins
d'indépendance énergétique donc la
filière estimée qu'il était peut-être
nécessaire de créer une filière de enfin
de biocarburant ou de e-carburant en
France afin d'avoir accès à un minimum
de carburant non fossiles pour ne pas
être dépendant de pays tiers qui
fixeraient des prix inappropriés ou qui
nous fixeraient des quotas voilà de
quotas de carburant donc il a été défini
de rapatrier au moins 1,5% des soudages
en France pourquoi puisqu'il faut savoir
que actuellement
pour tous les navires qui escale en
France non seulement 20% qui sont en
France les autres souTent à l'étranger
donc un cinquième de la flotte de navire
français et étrangers qui s'arrête en
France qui escale en France pour une
opération commerciale il y en a
seulement un cinquième qui saute en
France donc l'idée c'est peut-être
d'augmenter ce nombre de navires qui
souTent en France par le biais d'une
création de de de de
source enfin de biocarburant ou de
icarburant ce qui permettrait
d'améliorer encore plus l'attractivité
de nos ports français et surtout d'avoir
c'est indépendance énergétique
actuellement au sein des discussions que
nous avons avec le secrétariat général
de la planification écologique
effectivement cette notion de
d'augmentation de la
de la flotte et du soutage en France
créer des difficultés de de distribution
des de la biomasse et de l'électricité
entre les différents modes de transport
donc on revoit un petit peu à la baisse
nos objectifs et on applique plus de
leviers de sobriété et de technologie
donc je ne peux pas vous dire à quel
chiffre voilà les discussions vont vont
vont
aboutir mais voilà donc on a des ordres
de grandeur de d'énergie qui sera
nécessaire d'allouer aux Maritimes pour
les carburants et de biomasse mais ils
ne sont pas consolidés à ce stade tout
ce qui est plus ou moins
sûr à ce stade c'est que les premiers
carburants durables qui seront
accessibles aux navires et utilisés par
les navires ce sont des biocarburants
les i-carburants
n'apparaîtront que alors on a dit 2030
mais peut-être 2027 2028 voilà donc il y
aura un premier passage au biocarburant
et après un relais par les e-carburants
et après on verra
ultérieurement où se trouvera voilà la
répartition adaptée aura une révision de
cette stratégie de toute façon
ultérieurement
donc voilà donc je sais pas si donc nous
sommes en cours d'arbitrage une fois que
ces arbitrages sont pris aussi maire et
au travers de la SNBC
de juillet cette feuille de route
pourra être légèrement modifié et
deviendra la feuille de route état
filière
je prends la suite
c'est ce qui avait proposé
depuis longtemps par numéro de claquette
mais pas loin et après je passerai la
parole à notre apport très bien merci
monsieur le Président merci pour votre
invitation peut-être pour vous faire un
topo parce que vous avez visité
Marseille et le siège de CMA CGM je pars
revenir sur ce qui a pu vous être dit à
Marseille mais peut-être refaire une un
point de situation sur le modèle
économique des ports français on les
comparant au port du Nord-Europe parce
que nos grands concurrents sont en
Europe en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne et peut-être jeune et Barcelone
pour pour mon collègue de Marseille en
fait on est très carboné le notre modèle
économique est à peu près à 50% carbonée
c'est-à-dire que sur l'axe sens j'ai
deux grands raffineries les deux plus
grosses raffineries françaises une chez
Total à Gonfreville et une chez aixon à
Port Jérôme
et donc le l'avenir pour nous et
très important parce que quand on va
changer de modèle c'est à dire que quand
on va passer au monde d'après il va
falloir complètement transformer un
modèle industriel qui est basé sur le
pétrole ce qui est vrai chez nous est
vrai à Marseille encore plus il est vrai
encore plus à Nantes à Nantes on fait
encore du charbon on fait encore du gaz
et du Pétrole et donc on est dans une on
est tous dans une situation où la
transformation industrielle doit être
d'une part extrêmement rapide et d'autre
part il faut pas qu'on se trompe dans un
contexte qui est quand même assez
incertain alors la deuxième
caractéristique que je voulais évoquer
au début de cette table ronde c'est
que finalement tous ces produits ils
sont transportés ils vont vers des
clients alors vous aviez avant la
directrice générale d'Air France donc
nous on source la totalité des aéroports
parisiens et donc toutes les grandes
compagnies aériennes puisque l'axe scène
c'est le réseau de pipeline qui arrive à
Paris donc à Charles de Gaulle à Orly et
au Bourget
et qui va même jusqu'en Allemagne
puisque on livre le sud de l'Allemagne à
partir des dépôts pétroliers ou des
raffineries qui sont sur l'axe saine
donc on a en même temps un changement de
modèle puisque on imagine que le monde
carbone on va en sortir dans quelques
années on sait pas encore à quelle date
et en plus nos plus grands clients ceux
qui pèsent dans le monde français ils
sont pas très loin il faut qu'on arrive
à les sourcer
on est dans une on est dans un modèle
qui est assez unique en France puisqu'il
y a très peu d'endroits où on a une
telle densité de paris-pline qui permet
de créer ce fameux corridor alors le
corridor vous l'avez dit en introduction
un repas port c'est trois ports donc le
Havre Rouen et Paris et en même temps
appuyer sur un corridor qui permet
justement de distribuer et de livrer
tous ces nouveaux carburants
et ces nouveaux carburants dont on parle
on sait pas encore bien comment ils vont
se répartir on parle de i ammoniac on
parle de Yves méthanol on parle de bio
GNL on parle de ce que vous voulez on
parle même d'hydrogène
tout ça on est dans un
dans un faisceau où on sait pas très
bien ce que les les notamment les
compagnies maritimes vont choisir alors
on a une première période il y a entre 5
et 10 ans où les armateurs étaient
plutôt tournés vers le GNL puisque les
ports français d'ailleurs se sont mis au
niveau du soutage GNL pour pouvoir être
en mesure de d'assurer le ravitaillement
de ces navires alors on voit les
premiers portes conteneur au GNL qui ont
été soudés en France mais qui sont
plutôt soutés à Rotterdam moi Singapour
et puis on voit les bateaux de croisière
qui sortent des Chantiers de
l'Atlantique qui eux sont soudés dès
lors que l'escale permet de les Souter
et maintenant on est dans un deuxième
temps où tous les armateurs à conteneurs
puisque ce sont eux dont on parle on
parle surtout d'eux
se tourne vers une multitude de choix il
y en a qui se tournent vers l'ammoniac
qui est un produit qui est pas commun
notamment parce que il a des critères de
de dangerosité dès lors que ils
dispersent on a dû y méthanol qui est
une molécule qui est plus simple à
manipuler et puis on nous parle
aujourd'hui effectivement l'utilisation
de l'hydrogène et de la pile à
combustible pour pouvoir prendre faire
fonctionner les navires nous ce dont on
est persuadé et c'est on ça qu'on a bâti
notre notre stratégie à partir de 2020
quand on a créé finalement un repas port
c'est que en fait les ports doivent être
des points d'appui de cette
réindustrialisation verte qui passe par
une transformation des modes de
production des carburants ça c'est un
premier point et pour vous illustrer ça
et vous en avez aussi parlé on a un
enjeu extrêmement important sur notre
foncier puisque les ports sont
propriétaires de leur foncier et que les
ports disposent pour faire de ces
nouveaux carburants quelque chose qui
est important ce sont les utilités on
parle beaucoup de fabrication de des
carburants par des procédés qu'on
connaît depuis très longtemps les
fishertrops pour pas le nommer mais pour
faire du fisher-up pour pour faire du I
fioul en général il faut de l'eau il
faut de l'électricité en quantité et il
faut de la place pour faire une usine
une usine qui fait du Ikea Rosen
aujourd'hui et qui va fabriquer du SAF
qui
occupe 25 hectares de fonciers parce que
c'est à peu près la taille qu'il faut
pour faire 100000 tonnes uniquement de
if Youle c'est 25 hectares donc vous
imaginez que quand on doit sourcer en
2050 70% des 5 millions de tonnes de
carburant qui doivent aller dans les
aéroports parisiens vous imaginez le
nombre d'usines qu'il faudra déployer
pour avoir ce type de sourcing donc
c'est
important de de voir ça la deuxième
chose c'est que pour faire des
carburants donc on va passer par
l'hydrogène s'il faut l’hydrogène il
faut de l'électricité en quantité et
pour faire ces fameux 100000 tonnes dont
je vous parle il faut entre 250 et 300 m
d'électricité donc c'est pas à rien de
disposer de la puissance en question et
il y a pas beaucoup de territoire qui
permettent de le faire alors pourquoi le
faire dans les ports et finalement dans
des réseaux où il y a toutes ces
utilités c'est à dire de loin
industriels ou de la ou de l'électricité
c'est que demain il y a aussi un plan
d'équipements des parc éoliens au short
on les atterrages vont se trouver pas
très très loin des ports ou dans les
ports et ça donnera une source de
production d'électricité qui permettra
de créer ces séries carburants donc
on est un peu à la croisée des chemins
aujourd'hui avec un certain nombre
d'industriels il y a quelques annonces
qui vont arriver de nouvelles usines de
icarburant qui vont nous servir dans les
mois qui viennent qui vont nous servir
justement à pouvoir d'une part amener
des solutions pour les transporteurs
aériens et pour les transporteurs
maritimes en même temps mais c'est cette
caractéristique particulière de un repas
port qui est vraiment sur un corridor
spécifique où on a des pipelines et en
même temps une activité portuaire qui
permette en fait de faire la
coordination entre les deux voilà pour
pour ce propos liminaire que je voudrais
pas être plus long parce que je pense
qu'on aura des échanges de votre part
sur un certain nombre de questions
merci monsieur le rapporteur
merci c'est président merci à tous les
trois de vos exposer qui était
égaux dans la clarté et je voudrais
simplement dire que si d'autres filières
pouvaient s'inspirer de la clarté que
vous avez
déployé si je puis dire ça serait très
utile donc petit coup de chapeau
deuxièmement quand même vous ne nous
avez pas beaucoup dit en tout cas côté
état
qu'il y avait des questionnements sur le
la capacité de production et sur le prix
alors ce directeur général en filigrane
nous dit bien que il y a quand même des
sujets sur la capacité
électrique notamment et sur j'entends
bien là quand même relativement même si
vous avez des contre-exemples chez vous
et c'est bénéfique mais sur la
réactivité à faire sortir les projets
j'imagine en termes de financement quand
même pas mais sur sur ces deux points là
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
quand même un petit peu plus parce que
la filière a une feuille de route qui
paraît claire et bien éclairante mais
quand même on a le sentiment que voilà
il faut avoir comment on règlement de ce
marché alors est-ce qu'il faut le
réglementer est-ce qu'il faut le
laisser vivre et le rendre
se faire entre guillemets
comme marché qui fonctionne et avec des
clients solvables comment on fait par
rapport à ça
c'est mon premier sujet bon et puis
deuxième point je suis directeur général
vous allez vous indiquer effectivement
qui avait beaucoup de beaucoup de
projets là-dessus est-ce que ça vous
rend optimiser la capacité de production
j'ai démarré sur la deuxième question
parce que moi je enfin je vais juste
vous relater les appels à projets qu'on
mène sur ce type de secteur
les réponses sont nombreuses avec des
acteurs de très haut rang sur le plan
industriel avec des tickets
d'investissement pour des usines je
reparle de mon usine de 100000 tonnes
sur 25 hectares avec des tickets
d'investissement qui qui varient entre 1
milliard et un milliard et demi et donc
moi je sens que sur sur ces projets là
on a vraiment une capacité à agir de la
part des industriels et une volonté
d'agir après on rentre plus dans des
dans des difficultés techniques qui sont
liées à ce que je vous disais sur la
capacité à fournir les utilités
alors il y a des choses qui se passent
plutôt bien puisque dans la loi énergie
renouvelable
RTE a des pouvoirs qu'on peut entre
guillemets des missions complémentaires
qui lui permettent d'investir en propre
maintenant sur des transformateurs
électriques de fortes puissances donc ça
c'est c'est nouveau ça va leur permettre
normalement dans les mois qui viennent
de pouvoir investir en propre pour des
nouvelles installations quand on doit
faire un transformateur de de 400 MW si
on était dans le système ancien ça
prendrait entre 5 et 7 ans aujourd'hui
les temps vont être réduits grâce à
cette possibilité-là offerte offerte par
la loi et on a on attend un décret
d'application justement sur sur cette
possibilité donc ça c'est un premier
point mais il faut savoir que si vous
multipliez les 300 mégawatts par 10 15
ou 20 usines que les usines en question
consomment en moyenne 2 millions de
mètres cubes d'eau dans un contexte ou
l'eau elle sera raréfié il faut se poser
la question si à la fin on sera capable
de sourcer la totalité des carburants en
question donc capacité à fournir
l'électricité capacité à fournir l'eau
et puis organisation du système
et les porteurs de projets sont nombreux
voilà donc c'est le rôle des ports en
tant qu'aménageur de pouvoir programmer
ça donc nous on est bien dans ce rôle là
au niveau d'un repas port d'organiser ça
pour ça on a besoin de conserver notre
foncier donc on a un gros sujet autour
du zan mais bon PPL est
sorti du Sénat donc voilà donc ça c'est
et nous on s'y retrouve dans les ports
donc en tout cas dans les grands ports
donc ça c'est une première une première
décision positive et on attend
effectivement que l'on puisse faire
cette transformation industrielle parce
que on ne peut pas imaginer qu'on passe
d'un monde du raffinage à un monde des
nouveaux carburants sans consommer du
foncier
puisque les deux enfin on va pas
attendre d'avoir fermé le raffinage pour
faire les nouveaux carburants donc ça
c'est un point et qui est extrêmement
important pour nous donc on se prépare à
cette transformation en aménageant des
terrains en amenant les utilités et dès
lors qu'on aura fait ça on pourra
transformer l'Ancien Monde carbone en
autre chose et c'est tout l'enjeu de la
réintustrialisation verte donc on verra
avec le projet de loi industrie verte
dans les semaines qui viennent comment
on arrive à intégrer cette logique là
pour pouvoir aller plus vite dans les
aménagements de production de nouveaux
carburant moi c'est ce qui me soucie
c'est d'être dans le rythme et ce que
disait la collègue est tout à fait Brest
c'est à dire que si on n'est pas capable
nous de produire ces nouvelles molécules
les autres les auront avant nous il y a
une course aujourd'hui dans les ports du
Nord notamment à Rotterdam et à Anvers
qui sillonne le monde pour faire quoi
pour acheter du methanol faire des
partenariats pour acheter du methanol
pour acheter de l'ammoniaque pour
acheter de l'hydrogène
et qui sera le hub de distribution de
ces nouvelles molécules demain et
notamment Rotterdam qui est exposé à 50%
de son trafic en Rotterdam c'est 460
millions de tonnes et à peu près la
moitié en trafic de pétrole si vous
fermez les raffineries à Rotterdam il
faut trouver quelque chose pour pour
maintenir le modèle économique donc
c'est pour là ce sont rués sur les
nouveaux carburants les nouvelles
molécules donc nous il faudra aussi que
on soit très rapide dans notre capacité
de déploiement ce qu'on est en train de
faire en ce moment mais il faut aussi
qu'on puisse le faire sur le plan
foncier et sur le plan des utilités d'où
le partenariat avec RTU et d'où le
partenariat ou en tout cas des choses
qu'on travaille si on les écosystèmes
portuaires pour réutiliser l'eau pour
utiliser de l'eau industriel et pas
peser sur les milieux naturels pour
faire en sorte que cette eau soit prise
à d'autres usagers agriculteurs ville
etc donc il y a une question de vraiment
de préparation et d'anticipation pour ne
pas se retrouver à la traîne de nos
grands concurrents nos européens
[Musique]
petit captive et clairement les
transports international de conteneur et
dans cette configuration là c'est donc
gros consommateur de carburant mais ils
peuvent aller sous-ter dans différents
ports d'Europe et même hors d'Europe
aux fonctions des offres qui leur sont
faites et donc je dirais que les choix
qu'ils vont faire en termes de soutage
sont assez déterminants ensuite sur les
sur la façon dont les infrastructures
sont conçues et construites et puis il y
a une flotte une autre partie de la
flotte qui elle est captive et plus et
plus territorialisée je dirais ça comme
ça et qui elle pour le coup et et
tributaire de ce qu'on de ce que nos
ports et ça peut être des pores même de
taille plus modestes mettent leur
disposition en termes de en termes de
carburant des carbonés et donc c'est
notamment le cas des ferries ou de ou
des petits ou du capotage donc toute une
frétille qui est pas négligeable et qui
est qui même assez significative sur nos
ports et qui elles pour le coup et
plus captive et et se trouve enfin à
moins d'options ouvertes je dirais en
termes de en termes de choix
d'approvisionnement voilà donc on va
avoir ces deux ces deux cas de figure
enfin pour pour schématiser mais encore
une fois on a en tout cas les objectifs
je dirais et les cibles intermédiaires
on les a dans le règlement fluo maritime
donc qui était négocié récemment
oui si je peux je peux compléter aussi
au travers des travaux de la feuille de
route nous avons vu qu'il y avait
comment dire une discussion à lancer
entre les ports les énergéticiens et les
armateurs ce triptyque est indispensable
pour avoir une stratégie énergétique du
maritime qui soit qui soit
comment dire vraiment
intéressantes puisque les ports ont
besoin de clients les armateurs ont
besoin des ports et des énergéticiens il
faut que ces trois parties discutent
ensemble pour créer ces filières de
carburant durable de demain et donc dans
ce cette optique là nous avons une
décision chimère à actée c'est de
définir une stratégie de planification
énergétique maritime si possible par
façade maritime
puisque en fait on a besoin des
armateurs on a besoin des gros armateurs
donc vous en avez auditionné récemment
il dimensionnera probablement
une la planification énergétique
maritime française s'il décide de passer
tous ces navires au méthanol et de
Souter à repas il y aura une filière
immécanol extrêmement active et
puissante qui battra peut-être Rotterdam
voilà et il y aura tout le soutien qu'il
faudra pour voilà donc on a besoin
d'impliquer les armateurs aussi dans
cette stratégie énergétique et pour cela
il faut qu'on lance une sorte de tasse
que force à l'instar de ce qui a été
créé dans l'aérien une tasse que force
qui fasse discuter toutes les parties
les ports les armateurs les
énergéticiens l'état bien sûr et voilà
pour planifier ce déploiement
d'infrastructure énergétique
oui autant je voudrais claire tout à
l'heure autant là je trouve que météo
change un peu
comment il y a un peu de brouillard
parce que vous serez bien les premiers à
venir devant cette mission et à dire
tout va bien on va trouver le carburant
de demain dans le volume qui va bien et
au prix acceptable par le marché
mais quand je vous écoute je vais pas un
peu l'impression que que c'est réalité
là elles sont pas aperçues
non je crois que ce qu'a dit Monsieur
c'est que on était presque en retard par
rapport aux autres pays donc il faut se
mettre en ordre de bataille et discuter
avec ce fameux triptyque pour mettre en
place une stratégie déploiement
d'infrastructure de manière à avoir des
prix compétitifs à avoir l'hydrogène à
temps et pas avoir à l'acheter du côté
des Néerlandais parce que ils ont mis en
place toute une stratégie de
récupération de de l'hydrogène du Chili
et de l'Australie enfin bref donc il
faut se mettre en ordre de bataille pour
pas être en retard et là actuellement
nous sommes incapables de donner des
prix de l'énergie pour le maritime
puisque comme le disait monsieur
Christophe Lenormand c'est un marché
international donc les prix changent
tous les jours et en fonction et ils
changeront encore plus en fonction des
carburants qui seront choisis par les
grands armateurs donc on parle de
d'ammoniac a priori l'ammoniac perd un
petit peu maintenant c'est plus du
méthanol mais il y aura peut-être quand
même encore du bio GNL donc tant qu'on
n'a pas
des gros armateurs qui choisissent
l'énergie qui vont mettre aborder navire
de leur gros navire on saura pas quel
type d'infrastructures de carburant
maritime créé pour nos navires
oui mais alors comment on en sort parce
que là c'est le serpent qui se mord la
queue ça peut durer longtemps cette
affaire là il y a quand même une
relative urgence non enfin d'abord pour
clarifier peut-être les choses de ce
qu'on a compris chez certains armateurs
il y a un entre guillemets un modèle qui
paraît robuste parce qu'il y a pas de
changement de technologie finalement il
va de rupture technologique qui est dire
on commence par le GNL biognelle OK et
on finira alors après je sais pas dans
quel ordre et comment par ammoniac
methanol bon et tout ça on sait le faire
avec les mêmes navires en gros bon voilà
moyennant quelques adaptations sans
doute mais ça peut fonctionner est-ce
qu'on est d'accord là-dessus et après
comment comment on fait quand même parce
qu'au bout d'un moment le monde maritime
va se retrouver devant une interrogation
qui est vous êtes en retard par rapport
aux autres dans une compétition
internationale et par rapport à
l'attente quand même parce que là ça va
se résoudre quand votre affaire là
excusez-moi je suis un peu provocateur
et puis et puis j'ajoute qu'est-ce que
vous aimeriez que la mission regarde
comme hypothèse pour débloquer ça parce
que c'est ça la question
actuellement le vous parlez enfin les
hypothèses c'est pour 2030 alors ils
sont pas validés mais ça c'est d'avoir
un virgule Cinq Terres à watts de bio
GNL pour les navires 1,5
de biocarburant non identifié c'est du
biométhanol du biodiezel du bio et 1,2
térawattheure de if Youle en 2030 c'est
tout ce qu'on a on n'a pas plus de
détails puisque ça dépend encore une
fois de la molécule qui sera choisie par
nos amateurs
et pour le moment a priori c'est un mix
entre le GNL biogénal hygiénale et le
méthanol biométhanol iméthanol
l'ammoniac semble perdre un petit peu de
terrain du fait de cette dangerosité et
aussi probablement des missions
polluantes qui ne sont pas encore
identifiées réellement par les médias
juste pour redonner des ordres de
grandeur moi j'aime bien les ordres de
grandeur donc
de mémoire un grand port de conteneur de
de CMH CGM ça doit sauter à peu près
18000 m3 de carburant sur un
aller-retour
en 83 jours depuis l'Asie
une unité de production de bio GNL qui
va
rentrer dans un dans un investissement
qui peut peser autour de 300 à 400
millions d'euros c'est à peu près les 20
000 tonnes dont on parle voilà juste
pour vous donner des ordres de grandeur
donc des navires comme ça il y en a 12
pour faire une ligne complète entre 12
et 13
et il saute tous les 83 jours
ça vous donne les enjeux de production
c'est pour ça que je reviens à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est que quand
vous avez une
un produit qui s'appelle le pétrole brut
que vous allez transformer en fioul
lourd en gazole en essence et en
kérosène nous on en importe à peu près
20 millions de tonnes par an et avec ça
on va faire les carburants dont on parle
dont les 5 millions de tonnes de
kérosène dont on a besoin pour les
aéroports parisiens et donc je vous
donne les ordres de grandeur les ordres
de grandeur sur les après il y a les
taux d'incorporation au fur et à mesure
du temps puisque vous parliez d'aérien
juste avant nous donc vous allez avoir
5% 10% jusqu'à 70 % et une
usine de ce que je disais tout à l'heure
100000 tonnes de SAF
c'est entre 600 et 700 millions d'euros
pour 200 à 300 mégawatts de production
d'hydrogène
et on va faire une pour 1000 tonnes donc
vous voyez les les enjeux d'aménagement
et de transformation sachant
qu'aujourd'hui une raffinerie comme
Gonfreville ça occupe à peu près entre
200 et 250 hectares de terrain
donc la transforme ce que je voulais
vous vous que vous reteniez de mon
intervention c'est que la transformation
industrielle pour arriver au niveau de
production équivalent à ce que l'on
attend en 2030 2040 et 2050 elle est
majeure donc par rapport à votre
question sur mais alors vous êtes pas
clair etc ça va être une transformation
brutale
parce que il faut qu'on arrive à
switcher quelque chose sur lequel on
s'est appuyé depuis un siècle et demi
reconstruit à la prégère avec des unités
de production qui sont quand même
importantes 12 millions de tonnes de
raffinage à Gonfreville ou chez aixon à
notre homme de grand-banchon c'est une
grosse raffinerie et il va falloir
transformer ça en une multitude d'unités
pour arriver au même produit donc ça
veut dire une consommation de fonciers
Greenfield importante ça veut dire
consommation d'électricité importante et
tout ça dans un temps très court
assisté sur un point et ça a été un
parti rappelé par Stéphane mais sur le
fait que sur le transport maritime je
pense qu'à la différence peut-être des
autres secteurs que vous avez auditionné
dans le cadre de votre mission c'est
qu'en fait on a on a les contraintes
d'autonomie et de puissance à considérer
qu'ils sont quand même assez
particulières je pense à ce milieu là et
qui oblige à laisser ouverte plusieurs
options possibles et c'est pas par
défaut je dirais d'anticipation c'est
juste que et les autres pays ils sont
dans la même configuration que nous et
Dieu sait si on échange régulièrement
avec nos collègues européens sur ce
sujet là et même au-delà de l'Europe et
donc ça veut dire et c'est une forte
contrainte objectivement c'est
qu'actuellement on est obligé de laisser
ouvertes plusieurs options
technologiques possibles et ça se
retrouve donc comme le disait Stéphane
dans les infrastructures que l'on que
l'on imagine et que l'on commence à
construire et ça se retrouve évidemment
dans la structuration des flottes d'un
armateur c'est à dire que dans les au
donc vous avez faite et que vous allez
sans doute continuer à faire vous ne
trouvez pas d'armateur vous disant moi
j'ai la martingale avec pour ma flotte
une seule option possible et je sais
qu'avec ça je tiens la trajectoire la
trajectoire au mi et la trajectoire de
du Green Deal européen et c'est pas
faute de travail là-dessus c'est juste
que une question de maturité
technologique et et donc ça ça oblige et
c'est une vraie contrainte à avoir ces
ces différents faire au feu je dirais
pour l'instant et de pas se fermer de
pas se fermer prématurément certaines
options
pierre Cuypers merci le Président si
j'ai bien compris c'était une venez de
répondre une partie de ma question mais
je voudrais que être un peu plus clair
un navire qui va à Singapour
il fait sa charge du carburant d'énergie
aller-retour
ça veut dire que il a un poids mort à
l'aller
qui lui aurait permis de transporter de
la matière première le marchandise donc
l'économiquement et recharger là où il
arrive ça veut dire qu'il faut que les
infrastructures internationales qui
aujourd'hui est la même capacité de
répondre et là je reviens sur votre
feuille de route que j'apprécie d'avoir
abordé l'ensemble des énergies
disponibles
mais
ma question est la suivante est-ce que
vous avez fait un bilan économique de ce
qui serait la meilleure énergie
aujourd'hui qui pourrait répercuter sur
le consommateur infini
quel que soit les produits transportés
une économie liée au transport et à
l'énergie utilisée
ça pas encore en fait cette feuille de
route elle a été initiée en juin 2022
donc ça fait avec des des données du
maritime qui sont pas exhaustives peu
fiables et donc il n'est nécessaire de
de consolider donc actuellement dans le
plan d'action de la feuille de route il
y a quand même des actions d'études à
mener pour consolider toutes les
hypothèses prises dans cette feuille de
route donc c'est vraiment de la
macro-estimation parce que encore une
fois
le maritime c'est vraiment particulier
il y a des centaines de constructeurs
des centaines de lignes des prototypes
de navires enfin voilà c'est c'est assez
complexe et pour revenir pardon
oui tout à fait oui oui non mais c'est
c'est dans notre c'est normalement c'est
dans la feuille de route et pour revenir
à votre sujet de navire qui navigue vite
sans son carburant en fait une fois
qu'il a qu'il est quasiment enfin qu'il
a consommé la moitié de ses soutes le
navire doit de temps en temps prendre du
ballast donc de l'eau de mer se charger
une mer pour garder une assiette voilà
donc c'est pas forcément le cas ça
dépend des navires mais voilà c'est pas
forcément de la perte de cargaison parce
que de toute façon c'est pas très vrai
ce que vous dites parce que si Paris par
la charge par du Havre il va Singapour
il est à charge donc il a déjà c'est au
retour mais il va pas revenir à vide il
est
il est où qu'on a 18000 tonnes de
carburant et il va et pour revenir aussi
sur vos propos et sur les quantités
nécessaires à prévoir il faut savoir
aussi que les nouveaux carburants une
densité énergétique qui sera beaucoup
plus faible que celle des carburants
fossiles donc il faudra encore plus de
volume de carburant disponible
merci monsieur le Président merci pour
vos éclairages
je dois dire que la stratégie
énergétique maritime est un sujet
complexe et pour ne rien vous cacher je
vais vous dire d'où je viens je viens de
Bretagne
qui est une région un petit peu maritime
mais qui présente cette particularité
c'est que malgré ses 2700 km de côte la
Bretagne n'a pas de porc
de porcs
donc
c'est des gens en soi un sujet alors je
plaisante un peu en disant ça parce que
nous avons quand même à peu près nous
concentrons quand même à peu près tous
les problèmes
moi je tiens à ce que les lignes feeder
continue à desservir Brest
surtout quand on passe pour aller au
Havre
on a aussi des besoins logistiques
on a à peu près tous les types de
navires de plaisance
on a des navires pour la desserte des
îles
mais ces navires pour la desserte des
îles sont différents les
caractéristiques techniques de ces
navires ne sont pas les mêmes selon
qu'on dessert
ou essent ou saint avec des marnages à 5
mètres et le Golfe du Morbihan
les navires de pêche c'est encore une
autre caractéristique il existe encore
quelques navires de pêche et
j'étais encore il y a quelques jours
avec le secrétaire d'État à la mer bon
voilà donc je présente ça très
rapidement
en disant que
nous aurons besoin
de beaucoup d'expertise et de
recommandations pour définir un certain
nombre de choix publics
qui vont incomber finalement à des
autorités organisatrices de tout ça
parce qu'il faudra encore donner tout ça
et voilà donc il m'a paraît
utile
de les définir ensemble et je veux dire
ce n'est pas parce qu'on aura défini une
typologie ou une caractéristique de
carburant qu'on a réglé notre problème
logistique répondant besoin du
territoire
voilà je voulais peut-être avez-vous
sûrement d'ailleurs avez-vous réfléchi à
la question et vous voyez cette
complexité là on la vit quasiment au
quotidien et je n'ai pas parlé des ferry
qui est en soi un autre sujet et les
conséquences déjà de Marple qui a
précédé il a fallu déjà rétrocité nos
navires etc donc voilà vous avez
sûrement des éclairages à apporter mais
je vous demande de comprendre
à la fois une forme d'impatience c'est
le besoin d'expertise
monsieur Lenormand effectivement je
pense que le sujet que vous évoquiez il
revoit à la question de la flotte on va
dire la flotte dépendante c'est à dire
la flotte beaucoup plus territorialisée
donc à la fois la faute de pêche vous
l'avez dit et des petits navires de
commerce qui qui sont
par leur caractéristiques de toute façon
vont pas sauter ailleurs que dans leur
port de liaison régulière et donc ça
veut dire derrière avoir aussi alors à
leur échelle la disposition la
disponibilité je dirais en carburant des
carbonées donc c'est un des enjeux que
l'on a que l'on a bien en tête on parle
pas du tout des mêmes volumes mais mais
ça suppose aussi effectivement des
investissements dans les infrastructures
concernées et qu'on ignore pas dans la
dans la feuille de route là qu'on
évoquait parce que le parti pris a été
de dire évidemment le transport maritime
en termes d'émission de CO2
et le sujet pour nous princip mais on
pour autant on a appris le parti de
traiter aussi la question de la
décarbonation des fautes de pêche et des
fautes de présence mais c'est vrai que
les réponses ne sont pas les mêmes parce
que pour la faute de pêche avant tout de
réponse en terme effectivement
disponibilité dans les dans les ports de
pêche de carburant des carbone et aussi
de modernisation de la flotte de pêche
avec les contraintes que l'on connaît
liées à la politique commune des pêches
parce qu'on fait pas exactement ce qu'on
veut en terme de jauge de puissance
parce qu'il y a un encadrement par
rapport à ça donc ça contraint en fait
le sujet un peu plus que que sur la
flotte de commerce évidemment et puis
sur la flotte de plaisance je pense que
c'est avant tout dit solliciter dans les
ports notamment de branchement
électrique et aussi peut-être de
carburant des carbonés donc on a aussi
traité ce sujet là et c'est bien c'était
bien la tension
René Paul ça varie
vous vous parlez de phase intermédiaire
donc biocarburant au départ avant de
parler sur les
tous les compagnies sont pas les mêmes
moteurs mais au carburant c'est des
moteurs comme actuellement comme le
pétrole donc thermique et les autres
c'est des moteurs électriques non
pas forcément
ça dépend de la molécule en fait dans un
moteur diesel actuel que tous les
navires voilà on peut mettre du bio
diesel donc c'est à dire du diesel avec
du diesel fin de l'esther voilà mais on
peut mettre aussi du e diesel sans
changer le moteur peut-être quelque
paramètres d'huile ou de voilà mais pour
faire cette diesel il vous faut de
l'électricité oui tout à fait et donc le
problème c'est que c'est fait dans des
pays où l'électricité à base de charbon
ça peut être au détriment d'un tas de
choses puisqu'il faut beaucoup d'eau
beaucoup d'électricité alors je suppose
que on sait pas encore utilisé l'eau de
mer parce que ça règle le problème mais
ça interpelle quand au bilan au bilan
écologique ou cycle de vie quand on
regarde le cycle de vie en entier si
votre électricité elle est faite à base
de pétrole je vois pas bien ce qu'on a à
base de de charbon notamment je vois pas
bien ce qu'on a pu gagner dans dans
l'affaire il faut être attentif à tout
ça parce que hier soir il y avait un
reportage sur sur l'hydrogène à charge
sur l'hydrogène qui vont inquiéter qui
va inquiéter largement nos concitoyens
et à force on arrive même en étant au
cœur du sujet à se poser des questions
quand elle a durabilité même de ses
processus
la question que vous posez les remarques
que vous faites sont sont très justes
enfin dans les ports et c'est pour ça
que je parlais de localisation
industrielle de ces filières là dans les
ports
pourquoi à cet endroit là c'est parce
que l'écosystème permet un recyclage
complet je vais pas faire du Lavoisier
rien ne se perd rien de se créer tout se
transforme mais pas loin
quand vous avez ça reste vrai même même
après quasiment de siècles les quelques
de après après Lavoisier
si vous voulez le grand sujet c'est que
on a des boucles industrielles qui
permettent une réutilisation de l'eau si
on parle de l'eau on est sur de la
production d'électricité décarbonée
donc on est dans un système vertueux et
une modification du système industriel
c'est ce que je vous disais en début de
mon de mon intervention donc ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on doit faire très vite
pour ne pas être à la traîne de ce que
font nos concurrents nos européens donc
les boucles je vous donne un exemple la
station d'épuration du Havre elle
rejette 80000 mètres cubes d'eau traités
par jour dans les bassins du port si
vous arrivez à réutiliser ces 80000 m3
par jour ça tombe bien ils sont rejetés
juste à côté d'un transformateur
électrique de l'ancienne centrale au
charbon vous avez une capacité à faire
de l'hydrogène en réutilisant de l'eau
et en ayant de l'électricité parce que
vous avez un point d'arriver sur un
transformateur électrique donc c'est
l'endroit idéal où on peut le faire et
ces exemples là ne manquent pas dans les
ports il faut juste les combiner et sur
le plan industriel on a énormément
d'industriels qui s'intéressent à ça
alors après il y a la question du prix
la question du prix de la molécule
effectivement avoir un prix extrêmement
bas aujourd'hui dans le soutrage passer
à un prix de GNL qui est beaucoup plus
élevé puis passer à de lit-carburant qui
sera encore plus élevé
il faut que le modèle économique tienne
ce problème en fait de d'intensité
carbone des carburants sur l'ensemble de
la chaîne de fabrication du carburant
jusqu'à son utilisation dans les navires
donc ça c'est déjà traité au niveau de
l'Europe au travers donc du futur
réglement fiouloyou dont l'intensité
carbone couvrira donc de la création du
carburant la première goutte de
carburant jusqu'à son brûlage à bord des
des moteurs à l'eau émis il commence à
discuter de ce sujet mais ça avance très
peu puisque ce n'est pas dans l'intérêt
de certains pays
de passer à des énergies renouvelables
pour voilà fabriquer de l'électricité
verte pour faire des e-carburants mais
ça commence à monter au niveau
international et ce problème là crée
aussi un ralentissement du choix des
armateurs dans leur carburant puisqu'il
faut qu'il s'assure sur tous leurs
points de soudage que ces carburants
seront vraiment
disponibles et donc ils pourront pas
forcément sauter dans n'importe quel
port alors que le commerce international
se veut international et un navire peut
aller dans un affrontement dans
n'importe quel port du jour au lendemain
aujourd'hui donc c'est un vrai sujet et
pour le sujet effectivement des
écosystèmes régionaux c'est pour ça que
nous voulons aussi mettre en place une
stratégie de planification énergétique
maritime pour inscrire les solutions
énergétiques des navires captifs dans
l'écosystème local donc par exemple je
crois savoir quand qu'en Bretagne il y a
peut-être un écosystème hydrogène donc
voilà on voit déjà des navires des
projets de navire qui sortent qui
souhaiteraient sortir à l'hydrogène
puisque il y a une filière hydrogène
donc c'est bien après avec ce bémol que
faut pas non plus que le navire passe à
l'hydrogène alors qu'il pourrait passer
à l'électricité directe le rendement est
meilleur voilà donc 12 et nécessité
aussi de s'inscrire dans un écosystème
local pour la flotte domestique pour
trouver les solutions globales les plus
efficaces
oui merci d'avoir tout tous ces éléments
qui sont éclairants monsieur raison tout
à l'heure vous disiez que la question
c'était la capacité déploiement
notamment ce qui avait une course de
compétitivité concurrence entre les
entre les ports alors si vous deviez
nous donner deux ou trois mesures
qui pourraient entre guillemets aider
qu'est-ce que ça pourrait être peut-être
ou maintenant plus tard mais voilà c'est
le chant de notre travail nous on
essayait de mettre dans des débat public
et en lien avec tous les pouvoirs
publics de manière positive des pistes
ou des suggestions pour que on soit et
compétitif et qu'on avance bien dans la
transition écologiquement et puis
deuxièmement
j'entends bien et je valide l'idée de la
place stratégique des ports pour tout ça
bon mais par contre
on se dit que ce sont sur les
raffineries actuelles qu'on va trouver
les solutions ce qui est pas un paradoxe
à se remettre dans la main
de ceux qui produisent
aujourd'hui les énergies fossiles enfin
qui les raffinent ou qu'il est distribue
est-ce que c'est pas un handicap pour
faire sortir la filière de
du point de vue économique je veux dire
par là parce que
je vais pas faire une réponse de Normand
mais quasiment
mais oui mais j'en suis puisque j'y
habite donc
je dans les dans les porteurs de projets
on a tout type de porteur c'est à dire
qu'on peut avoir des sociétés qui sont
dans le monde du raffinage aujourd'hui
et on a aussi beaucoup de sociétés qui
sont des énergéticiens et qui ne sont
pas dans le domaine du raffinage donc
c'est assez ouvert parce que tout le
monde a bien compris que que le marché
de développement sur ces carburants là
il est énorme enfin remplacer les
millions de barils actuels par des
nouveaux carburants c'est c'est un
marché qui est inédit dans un laps de
temps qui est très court donc moi je
pense que et d'ailleurs on le voit dans
nos appels à projets on a des sociétés
extrêmement diverses et pas que des gens
du raffinage ça c'est le le premier
point
la recommandation si si on allait vers
la recommandation moi je pense qu'on a
on a nos besoins
mais mais on le voit et on va le voir je
pense dans le dans le projet de loi
industriel verte on a besoin de pouvoir
accélérer ces projets là accélérer sur
le plan réglementaire donc c'est nous
une de nos demandes depuis des années
dans les ports alors je demande pas un
statut d'exception je demande juste de
faire en sorte que quand on a une usine
de nouveau carburant quand on a voilà
tous ces projets de réindustrialisation
verte quand ils sont localisés au bon
endroit et qu'on a déjà une
acceptabilité territoriale parce qu'il
faut pas mes estimer les questions
d'acceptabilité je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir
faire en sorte que dans ces écosystèmes
où on a on connaît le risque industriel
on a toutes les utilités on est capable
d'avoir tous les industriels rassemblés
autour d'un même projet on doit pouvoir
faire plus vite
dans les projets c'est la recommandation
que je ferai il y en a une première mais
mais vous l'avez vous-même dit c'est le
zéro artificialisation net pour qu'on
puisse conserver une capacité d'aménager
sur nos espaces donc voilà ça il y a une
première phase qui a été passée avec la
PPL l'état il y a peu de temps
avec une mesure spécifique pour les
grands ports voilà j'espère que on ira
au bout et que on aura ce on aura cette
capacité là à continuer à aménager en
attendant de changer de monde si je peux
le résumer ainsi
Lucien
nous sommes arrivés en retard parce
qu'on était à l'hémicycle en train de
voter des une loi
ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est qu'en fait vous êtes vous
gestionnaire de de port
et donc vous avez des clients qui vous
demandent des carburants
et puis derrière vous avez
où vous n'avez pas d'ailleurs l'État qui
vous dit on va plutôt là on va plutôt là
est-ce que je comprends pas que c'est
quel est votre rôle vous qui est au
milieu là qui est distributeur de
produits en fonction de la demande de du
client
puisqu'il semblerait que les clients et
des solutions multiples et variées quoi
puisqu'on parle d'hydrogène on parle de
biocarburant par l'électricité
effectivement et donc vous gérez ça au
fur et à mesure comme ça là où il y a
une ligne directrice quoi qui alors nous
on n'est pas des distributeurs on est
des aménageurs c'est à dire que le le
port après la réforme portuaire de 2008
est devenue un aménageur il était avant
un exploitant portuaire il est devenu un
aménageur donc nous on aménage des
terrains du domaine public pour amener
des industriels ce sont ces industriels
qui discutent avec les armateurs ou avec
les compagnies aériennes parce que voilà
on ne source pas que des armateurs on
source aussi ce qui se passe sur terre
et donc nous on met à disposition du
foncier aménagé pour faire en sorte que
des industriels de tout type
énergéticiens pas énergéticien raffineur
paraffineur enfin voilà de tout type
puissent développer des activités en
fonction des besoins qui sont exprimés
par les clients donc les grands
armateurs qui touchent aujourd'hui le
port ils seront tous quasiment sur le
conteneur tous les armateurs mondiaux
ces gens-là vont nous dire demain est-ce
que vous avez des biognelles est-ce que
vous avez du méthanol est-ce que vous
avez ça mais c'est pas nous qui allons
donner cette réponse là ce sont des
entreprises qui sont installées chez
nous et qui auront réalisé les unités de
production en question ça c'est notre
rôle
voilà et on le fait dans un cadre public
puisque on est sur du domaine public
sur les puisque vous êtes parmi nous
ce que vous pouvez
l'intersection ou la relation
maritime fluviale comment elle se situe
comment elle peut évoluer
ils ont ils ont les mêmes ils ont les
mêmes besoins des échelles complètement
différentes c'est à dire que quand on
voit un armateur qui a un
porte-conteneur je citais les portes
conteneurs de CMA CGM ou de MC
d'ailleurs c'est les mêmes pour se pour
les plus grands qui touchent le Havre
aujourd'hui on les armateurs fluviaux
ont avoir les mêmes contraintes alors
sur les j'ai pas parlé de tout ce qu'on
fait en matière de branchement à quai
qui qui fait partie de la réglementation
européenne donc tout ce qu'on fait sur
les aménagements de branchements à quai
sur les sur les quais du Havre de Rouen
ou de Paris puisqu'on développe un
réseau quasiment d'une centaine de
bornes électriques pour pouvoir
alimenter les navires en escale ça c'est
un premier point un deuxième point qu'on
fait pour les armateurs fluvio ce sont
des points de livraison de ce qu'on
appelle multi énergie notamment sur nos
plus grandes plateformes à Gennevilliers
à Montereau à Bonneuil-sur-Marne et à
Limay on aura un réseau de station
multi-inergy qui permettra de fournir
aux armateurs fluviaux
une nouvelle molécules dont ils ont
besoin mais ce sont les mêmes que celles
qu'on va retrouver dans le maritime donc
est-ce que demain on aura de l'hydrogène
est-ce qu'on aura du GNL est-ce qu'on
aura des biocarburants les biocarburants
c'est déjà le cas les armateurs fluvio
ont fait un gros effort pour passer au
biocarburant donc il s'alimente
notamment auprès de fournisseur qui sont
à Rouen aujourd'hui société comme Paul
qui fait partie du groupe avril qui qui
fournit les bruits les biocarburants
pour les armateurs fluvio et et ils sont
dans la même transformation eux aussi
avec des enjeux encore de visibilité
encore plus profond puisque je rappelle
que l'année prochaine on aura la
cérémonie d'ouverture des JO qui se
passent sur la scène et que une grande
partie de la flotte est en train de se
décarboner donc il y a des gens qui
passent à l'électrique il y en a qui
sont biocarburant et il y en a qui vont
vers aussi des nouvelles molécules donc
on a la même chose mais à un niveau qui
est différent puisque les quantités sont
pas les mêmes mais en tout cas on
poursuit sur le corridor ce que l'on
fait dans le port pour les armateurs
maritimes on le poursuit aussi sur le
fluvial
sur la porteur
mes chers collègues
et
notre collègue salarié à soulever des
éléments de la complexité fort
intéressant je pense qu'on en
rediscutera quand on fera un point sur
l'évolution de notre mission
bien madame mais messieurs merci d'avoir
répondu présent à notre invitation et
puis merci beaucoup de votre éclairage
voilà et une fois encore je pense que
quantifier les choses c'est extrêmement
important pour comprendre ce qui nous
attend